if you if you really want to do only
fans like my friends who do only fans
it's really hard work don't do this no
pun intended but um but it is it's not
like I'm just gonna get naked and get
money it's like literally what we do but
with sex and trying to keep that
momentum going because a lot of people
will pay for a month of only fans and if
it's like four videos and like they
already saw it and then you move around
so how do you keep that going so it's
lots of times editing lots of times
going back responding to every single
message it's lots of time you know they
make private videos for people they're
responding oh yeah oh yeah usually an
agency will just have like what agency
no this is how a lot of the girls do it
yeah well that's straight I don't
understand okay yeah then gotta work for
it man so it's hard work so I think yeah
you can make a quick cash grab if you're
hot and you wanted to like I don't know
if I wanted to do only fans for a month
just quick pasta naked
[Laughter]
really thinking about it so Andrew if
you want to support me thank you